in central Africa lies a vast tropical
forest the size of India the Congo Basin
its trees absorbs more carbon than the
Amazon and it's referred to as our
planet's other lung
Guided by indigenous pygmies we travel
deep inside where Cameroon meets
Equatorial Guinea we encounter an elder
speaking to a tree
an uncomfortable conversation between a
member of a community that's considered
the forest custodian and what they see
as the spirit of this Forest that's
because the pygmies have been hired by
logging companies to help them cut down
trees and take part in destroying their
own habitat
we're not proud of proud of what we're
doing because some of the trees have
medicinal properties the forest is like
our Pharmacy so even though we work with
the login companies we try to protect
what we can the logging companies
persuaded the pygmies to leave their
Forest they have been given housing with
amenities like electricity that alter
their way of life they no longer go
foraging instead the pygmies serve as
guides to logging companies looking for
valuable wood for their work each
receive ten dollars a day
the pygmies love this tree they call it
the numumbo it's known for its medicinal
properties and it's warm fragrance but
look at it now
each centimeter of this dump represents
a year of life this isn't a tree that's
hundreds of years old it's thousands of
years old cut to the ground and it's one
of many
the timber is shipped from a nearby port
to Asia to make furniture that will be
sold to people in wealthier countries
Recent research suggests a quarter of
this rainforest could Disappear by 2050
because of logging
and yet the Congo Basin stores around 20
billion tons of carbon that's around
three years worth of global greenhouse
gas emissions
it is a precious natural barrier to
climate change and its trees are values
not for a few but for Humanity and
planet Earth itself
Nicholas Hawk Al Jazeera Pandey Southern
Cameroon